what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel Studios not only confirm the
importance of Loki season 2 of course in
the Multiverse Saga but also how
important Loki and Sylvia themselves are
going into Avengers Secret Wars and
hearing quite a bit of things about Loki
season 2 especially coming straight from
Marvel kind of sheds some light on what
exactly to expect for the ending of Loki
season 2 looks like we have a pretty
decent idea of what exactly is going to
happen don't worry we're not talking any
spoilers like who could possibly die but
it doesn't look like things are going
back to normal for Loki and Sylvie this
is coming from Marvel Studios producer
Kevin Wright who has been doing a lot of
interviews for the Show recently because
they had the wga strike before where
nobody could basically promote the movie
and the writer strike is still happening
right now hopefully that gets resolved
pretty soon but basically the only
promotions that they could have for the
movie are inhouse so people who are
actually with Marvel Studios and Kevin
Wright has done a great job recently
going around doing a lot of different
interviews and he's been giving us a lot
of great information actually so we'll
dive into what he has recently said
about the connection between Loki season
2 and Secret Wars and talk about how
Loki is not only going to affect Secret
Wars but a lot of other shows coming up
in the meantime as well and if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos also if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
well the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month now right away go ahead and let us
know if you liked season 2 episode 1 of
Loki a lot of people have been stating
Marvel is back and they have actually
hit some big numbers with Loki season
2's Premiere that Marvel hasn't hit in a
very long time for those curious within
the first 3 days of the Loki season 2
premiere they racked in 10.9 million
views this is the most out of any Disney
plus project in 2023 except the season 3
premiere of the Mandalorian the Ahsoka
Premiere hit 14 million Global views in
the first 5 days but did not hit 10.9 in
the first 3 days so it's a pretty big
deal a lot of people are really excited
about Loki and a lot of people have even
said that it saved Marvel and Marvel is
back but I think Loki and Sylvie might
actually save the MCU within the MCU
defeating Kang variants as well so as I
mentioned Marvel Studios producer Kevin
Wright has been doing a lot of
interviews this interview is with
comicbook.com phase zero podcast and in
the interview when discussing how Loki
affects the rest of the MCU moving
forward this is what he said as we were
developing Loki we were kind of like oh
in a broad sense it would be really cool
if the coming phases also ran through
Loki and his choices but in a different
unexpected way it always I mean those
are kind of like broad discussions but
we always are focusing in on just just
what we're doing and trying not to get
too bogged down by the bigger picture if
we tell our story really well the rest
of the MCU will embrace it now there's
more to this he goes on to specifically
talk about Sylvie but let's talk about
this first part real quick when he says
that it would be really cool if the
coming phases also ran through Loki
anda's choices there are a few different
things that can actually be affected
here one is if you go all the way back
to the finale of Loki season 1 that's
obviously a huge event Loki is
essentially created the Multiverse there
technically Sylvie or I should say they
have Unleashed yet again the Multiverse
because as we learned in Loki episode 1
in season 2 it looks like the Multiverse
kind of exists as raw time but Kang's
invention the time Loom brings them all
together and weaves them into one main
timeline so essentially it looks like
sylv and Loki kind of undid that and
that kind of is the basis of Secret Wars
the ability of the Multiverse to
actually exist exist there couldn't be a
Multiverse a war without the Multiverse
being into play and that's exactly how
he who remains in Loki season 1 won he
defeated other timelines with the
strongest Kings and then he secluded his
own timeline and kept branches from
branching out but now everything is
undone even if the time Loom is still
there they are no longer pruning
branches that pop out of the main
timeline essentially creating a million
different variants of can infinite
different variants of King so choices
one and two one to kill Kang the
Conqueror SL he who remains essentially
created the Multiverse again in the MCU
and two choosing to not prune those
branch timelines also keeps intact the
Multiverse so obviously this plays a big
effect and this obviously brings in our
villains Kang and somewhere out there in
the Multiverse is the Council of Kings
Morse ramut and the Scarlet Centurion
these King variants coming to power are
a direct result of what Loki and Sylvie
did now he also says the other phases
are going to be affected by their
decisions in a different but unexpected
way some of these we probably haven't
seen yet because Loki obviously still
has a lot more choices to make in Loki
season 2 but in the interview
comicbook.com said so Tom heston's Loki
is the Catalyst for Secret Wars
confirmed thank you very much in which
Kevin Wright said Sylvie has a lot of
responsibility in that too by the way
with what she's done with the Multiverse
now obviously what we said before about
the finale of Loki season 1 remains true
everything they did essentially allowed
Secret Wars to be created however we are
now getting into the personal decisions
that Loki and Sylvia are going to be
making in season 2 for example we know
that they are going to run into Victor
timley and other variants of King the
Conqueror as well and we don't know
what's going to happen with these
variants are they going to be good are
they going to be bad is Sylvie going to
go out and kill each one of these
variants we are unsure at this moment
but what we do know is that the decision
that Tom heston's Loki is struggling
with in Loki season 2 so far the
decision of whether pruning the
timelines is right or wrong and whether
they should continue to do it or not in
order to keep Kang and his variants away
well it looks like that decision is
pretty much made by the end of Loki
season 2 and whether that's made by him
or it's made by somebody else forcing
him to do it it's made and what's going
to end up happening is nothing
essentially they're going to continue to
allow the timeline to Branch out this is
going to create other universes and it's
going to create other variants of Kang
and we know this because of what is
going to happen in Deadpool 3 the TVA is
going to be in Deadpool 3 and it sounds
like Owen Wilson's Mobius is going to
have a pretty decent role in that movie
as well however here is where we are
going to start to see the backlash of
the decision to not prune any timelines
which is the multivers of war that is
the backlash we already know that in
Deadpool 3 Deadpool and Wolverine are
going to visit a lot of different
universes and we know that incursions
are going to start to happen happen a
lot and we're going to see them we also
know that the TVA is going to play a
huge role in Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars
because they are going to save certain
heroes from dying universes and bring
them all together on one planet sort of
like battle world in the comics now the
other day I put out a theory that Loki
is going to rule the TVA by the end of
Loki season 2 and possibly the end of
the Multiverse Saga and put together
sort of a multiversal Avengers team to
try and help save the universe because
Loki and Sylvie want free will for
everybody but they also can't have the
Multiverse being destroyed so what Loki
and Sylvie could do is monitor the
Multiverse and anytime there's a king
that gets out of control they send the
multiversal Avengers team of crazy
powerful superheroes from many different
universes to go and take on a variant or
many variants of King the Conqueror
which essentially is what we are going
to get in Avengers Secret Wars here's
what we've heard from insiders in
Deadpool 3 the TVA will indeed start to
save a a bunch of Heroes put them in one
place and then start to kind of use them
to fix the Multiverse this mainly comes
in the form of Secret Wars with us
hearing a report that the TVA is going
to send the multiversal Avengers team to
Earth 616 to help them in their battle
against King to help restore the entire
Multiverse since by the time we get to
Secret Wars we assume it's pretty much
going to be destroyed at least a lot of
it with a lot of incursions having
happened and many universes having been
destroyed so this is how Loki and Sylvie
are major players for Secret Wars they
have essentially saved or released the
TVA from what they used to know and
moving forward the decision has been
made to not prune any of the timelines
and remember what he who remains said
the two of them could run the TVA
together in order to ensure the chaos
doesn't break out and it seems like that
is essentially what is going to happen
and the TVA is going to play a huge role
in Saving a bunch of different people
from the incursions that are happening
in the Multiverse and of course this is
just one of many ways in how we are
going to see a lot of different variants
in the MCU in secret Wars plus not to
mention one of the main ways Loki and
Sylvia are going to be involved in
secret Wars is that they know Kang they
know he who remains they know what he
told them he who remains explained to
them how the first multiversal war
started how he defeated all the other
kings with elath and what he did to make
sure no other king variant arrived they
have information that is crucial plus
not to mention they'll have the TVA at
their disposal so they're going to be
extremely powerful players in Avengers
Secret Wars and it's nice to hear that
Kevin Wright said Sylvia is along for
the ride as well since yeah she did have
a big part to play in the Multiverse
essentially being let loose again so go
ahead and let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
are you excited for more of Loki season
2 and how do you think Loki and Sylvie
are going to play big roles in secret
Wars let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to not miss out
on any of the latest Loki and MCU news
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof